i was auditioning for the first x-men my  passport was expiring under six months  which apparently you're not supposed to  travel blah blah blah so they were like  whatever you do don't tell them that  you're here for work because they'll ask  for a work visa say you're here for  pleasure and i'm like oh my good god  i have to lie to a customs officer and  so i'm working myself up so much through  the line i'm like okay i just have to  have a backstory i got it back and i  have to believe it  and um and so he gets there and he was  like business or pleasure and i was like  pleasure what are you doing for pleasure  my brother's getting married  and he was like where's he getting  married wimbledon  is he american yes  do you have an invitation no  are you telling the truth no no  [Laughter]  i felt tiny